how you tell a joke and something I
admire about you is just your mindset
and I'm curious as a comedian not only
just mental health but what is the value
of having your mind set and how does
your offstage mindset affect your
onstage performance and that's a good
question I'm gonna try to take my time
way if you don't mind
absolutely well it kind of came to me
pretty early in comedy from going to
open mics I would see different types of
styles and I would see people especially
when I started it was during you know
the Bush years in people who loved to do
politics jokes then and they loved to
just make fun of him and and and rip him
apart and I would see these acts and I
remember seeing one guy in particular he
seemed so angry and so like really
invested in it and then I see him
offstage and I was like wow like oh you
really get so angry about that I mean I
must suck that suckers like but that
must be hard for you to live with and
he's like oh I don't really feel that
way you know it's an act and I was like
oh well then why did you do it you know
that's how I looked at it and I looked
at the job and I understood that it
wasn't like it wasn't always improv you
know it wasn't coming up with a new joke
every time you went onstage you might
work on some wording you might change
things up but a lot of times you know
you're working on your act over and over
and over again and so I decided that if
I wanted if I had to say the same things
over and over again that I wanted to
talk about things I loved and I want to
talk about things that made me happy not
things that I didn't want to give power
to things that I hate it you know I feel
that the Trump election was a big
indicator of that like you had right up
until he was elected everyone was like
oh he's a joke he's an idiot he's this
he
that he's just reality star but I could
tell just from the amount of talk in the
universe it was all about him whether it
was negative or positive it was about
him and to me when you do that you give
that entity a lot of power and so I
wanted to like if I want to bring power
to things I want to bring power to
things that I love and enjoy things that
some people make fun of like you know
pro wrestling or video games or monogamy
or whatever like things that I like and
that I enjoy I'd rather give them more
power than they can constantly be like
oh can you believe this is going on you
know and I think there's still a value
to that there's always a value to
speaking truth to power and calling out
and I try never to shy away
from that but I didn't want to I didn't
never want in my stage life in my real
life to be far apart from each other I
felt that the most successful comedians
and the people who I looked up to were
people who who would be joking around
backstage and then get on stage and be
the same exact person how are you able
to how that's something as commands we
struggle with is like we want to be
funny offstage like we are on stage how
were you able to like tighten that gap
over time preparing this day she doesn't
she'll get weirded out by because oh
heavens it's set and she's like what are
you gonna do and I just like I don't
know like I'll figure it out when I get
up there and so I a lot of it came from
reading and watching Garry Shandling's
documentary and biography of staying in
the moment and trying not to like show
people like this is an act you know I
wanted to I once I watch that
documentary I started to set this rule
of myself that I would always start by
just being in the moment I would never
start with like a plan joke I would
always just talk about what at
whatever's going on hey hot brother and
sister if you love comedy as much as we
do here at hot breath click the
subscribe button to join the hot breath
averse and then watch more videos to get
even more comedy tips